get vaccinated that is the message
tonight from health officials
as the delta variant is spreading across
portions of the united states thank you
for joining us
at 6 p.m i'm brian lofton and i'm sasha
loftis the cdc is concerned
young adults are most at risk here kate
houston spoke to some young adults in
our area about their decision
to not get vaccinated opinions vary for
young adults on the covet 19 vaccine
a lot of my friends are split a lot of
my office are split
it definitely seems closer to 50 50 than
i thought it would have been
29 year old andrew levitt has dealt with
hypertension since he was a kid
he's currently on the fence after
previous reports of blood clots from the
johnson and johnson vaccine
caused him to worry about the effects of
it on his health
every other day i'm contemplating maybe
i just go get their own thing
it really is something that i debate
pretty much
at least weekly for some young adults
like 18 year old brodie shulin rivkin
his battle with asthma was his catalyst
for getting the vaccine
i'm more prone to severe symptoms of
cover 19.
so ultimately i just made sure that i
was safe as well as everybody else
around me
health officials say the lack of
vaccines can also be attributed to young
people
not thinking the virus will impact them
but as the fast spreading delta variant
hits the u.s
doctors say that's not the case as we
see more confirmed cases in the younger
population
we are as these new variants pop up
going to see more hospitalizations
in the younger population dr christina
madison says the delta variant doesn't
care about age
and as adolescents and young adults head
back to school in the fall
a lack of vaccine could cause even more
spread
we're still in the middle of a pandemic
and as much as we think that we're done
with this virus
this virus is not done with us kate
houston 8 news now
at this time the southern nevada health
district says it does not have enough
evidence to
show the delta variant is significantly
impacting case counts here in clark
county
at last check 13 cases of the delta
variant were found
as variants spread across the state u.s
officials encourage
all eligible adults to get the vaccine